And you didn't, like, you weren't going to inform me of that? I mean, I'm not in New York, the city. I'm in Montauk, which is like four hours away from New York. It's on Long Island. It's at the very end of Long Island, which is quite long, to be totally honest. Yeah. Well, you're going to have to come hang out with me. Nope.
And you didn't, like, you weren't going to inform me of that? I mean, I'm not in New York, the city. I'm in Montauk, which is like four hours away from New York. It's on Long Island. It's at the very end of Long Island, which is quite long, to be totally honest. Yeah. Well, you're going to have to come hang out with me. Nope.|||而你居然——我是说，你没打算告诉我这件事吗？我的意思是，我不在纽约市，我在蒙托克，距离纽约大约四个小时的车程。它在长岛上。它在长岛的最末端，说实话，长岛真的很长。是的。好吧，你得来跟我一起玩。才不要。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 128 recorded on May 3rd, 2023. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about GCC 13.1 and our upcoming conferences. And InBall Levy is crashing on my couch on her way to C++ Now, and at some point she's going to need to come back from the office. Isn't C++ Now happening right now, or is it next week? I think it's next week next week i mean i would assume it's next week because in ball's here and she's the the program chair um so yeah presumably she says she'll be done at work at at 4 20 which is eight minutes from now and then she'll come over here and I don't know. I think it could be a five or ten minute walk
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 128 recorded on May 3rd, 2023. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about GCC 13.1 and our upcoming conferences. And InBall Levy is crashing on my couch on her way to C++ Now, and at some point she's going to need to come back from the office. Isn't C++ Now happening right now, or is it next week? I think it's next week next week i mean i would assume it's next week because in ball's here and she's the the program chair um so yeah presumably she says she'll be done at work at at 4 20 which is eight minutes from now and then she'll come over here and I don't know. I think it could be a five or ten minute walk|||欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 128 期，录制于 2023 年 5 月 3 日。我是 Connor。今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊 GCC 13.1 以及我们即将参加的会议。InBall Levy 在去参加 C++ Now 的路上借宿在我的沙发上，她一会儿得从办公室回来。C++ Now 是现在正在举行，还是下周？我觉得是下周。下周。我的意思是，我猜是下周，因为 InBall 在这儿，而她是——她是节目主席，嗯，所以是的，据她所说，她将在 4 点 20 分下班，也就是从现在算起的八分钟后，然后她会来这儿，我不知道。我觉得步行大概需要五到十分钟。
if one knows which direction they're going. But it could be longer if you're not a native New Yorker. Well, depending on how long it takes her, we'll record until she shows up and then she can say hi. And then we'll cut the episode. Yeah. And I just looked. I did tell her to give me a heads up before she enters.
if one knows which direction they're going. But it could be longer if you're not a native New Yorker. Well, depending on how long it takes her, we'll record until she shows up and then she can say hi. And then we'll cut the episode. Yeah. And I just looked. I did tell her to give me a heads up before she enters.|||前提是你知道自己该往哪个方向走。但如果你不是土生土长的纽约客，可能需要更长时间。好吧，这取决于她要花多长时间，我们会一直录音直到她出现，然后她可以打个招呼。接着我们就会剪辑这期节目。是的。我刚看了看。我确实告诉过她进门前先跟我打个招呼。
Yeah. C++ now, May 7th to May 12th. Probably if you're going, you've got your tickets already. And by the time this comes out, it's going to be, what is it? May 3rd today we're recording this. And so that means it's going to be May 5th. All right. Yeah.
Yeah. C++ now, May 7th to May 12th. Probably if you're going, you've got your tickets already. And by the time this comes out, it's going to be, what is it? May 3rd today we're recording this. And so that means it's going to be May 5th. All right. Yeah.|||是的。C++ Now 会议在 5 月 7 日到 5 月 12 日。如果你要去的话，可能已经买好票了。等这期节目发布的时候，会是什么时候？今天是 5 月 3 日，我们在录音。这意味着发布时将是 5 月 5 日。好的。是的。
So for those listening on their way, have fun. Do you have a topic today to chat about? I got nothing. All right. Then today we shall mostly do a... My mind is empty. I am an open vessel. I am prepared to learn.
So for those listening on their way, have fun. Do you have a topic today to chat about? I got nothing. All right. Then today we shall mostly do a... My mind is empty. I am an open vessel. I am prepared to learn.|||所以对于在路上收听的听众，祝你们玩的开心。你们今天有什么话题可以聊吗？我没什么好聊的。好吧。那我们今天主要来……我的脑子空空如也。我是一个空空的容器。我已经准备好学习了。
All right. Well, you're probably not going to learn much. We're going to probably... We'll spend a little bit of time recapping or recapping. That's the wrong word. Previewing our upcoming conference talks. But before we do that, and travel plans, before we do that, GCC. Oh, God.
All right. Well, you're probably not going to learn much. We're going to probably... We'll spend a little bit of time recapping or recapping. That's the wrong word. Previewing our upcoming conference talks. But before we do that, and travel plans, before we do that, GCC. Oh, God.|||好吧。嗯，你大概学不到什么东西。我们可能会……我们会花一点时间回顾，或者说回顾——用错词了。是预览我们即将进行的会议演讲。但在那之前，还有旅行计划，在那之前，是 GCC。哦，天哪。
I think you need a PhD to understand my travel plans. All right. We don't need to necessarily focus on the travel plans. We'll focus on the conferences, and then we'll chat about our week, just under a week long road trip, which goes through Slovenia. Anyways, before we chat about that, GCC long awaited release 13.1 just dropped last week. It's been out for a week. And what does that mean, folks? You now have access to all of the wonderful range adapters
I think you need a PhD to understand my travel plans. All right. We don't need to necessarily focus on the travel plans. We'll focus on the conferences, and then we'll chat about our week, just under a week long road trip, which goes through Slovenia. Anyways, before we chat about that, GCC long awaited release 13.1 just dropped last week. It's been out for a week. And what does that mean, folks? You now have access to all of the wonderful range adapters|||我觉得你得有个博士学位才能看懂我的旅行计划。好吧。我们没必要非得关注旅行计划。我们先聊聊会议，然后聊聊我们为期不到一周的自驾游，这次旅行会穿过斯洛文尼亚。不管怎样，在我们聊这个之前，备受期待的 GCC 13.1 版本上周刚发布。它已经发布一周了。大家知道这意味着什么吗？你们现在可以使用所有那些精彩的范围适配器了
that are coming in C++ 23. I just spent the last, I've had it working for about four hours now. I spent 22 hours, including sleeping, trying to get a working version of GCC 13.1. Boy, oh boy. My final tweet on the topic was, I can't believe it's easier to install a Linux OS than it is to get a cutting edge GCC version. I tried to compile it for the longest time, left it overnight, didn't work, but I was doing it from like a mounted Windows volume within WSL2, which I shouldn't have been doing. But then even when I went to WSL2, it looks like it built in 30 minutes, but then I couldn't find the executable anywhere. Yeah, when I started off my career,
that are coming in C++ 23. I just spent the last, I've had it working for about four hours now. I spent 22 hours, including sleeping, trying to get a working version of GCC 13.1. Boy, oh boy. My final tweet on the topic was, I can't believe it's easier to install a Linux OS than it is to get a cutting edge GCC version. I tried to compile it for the longest time, left it overnight, didn't work, but I was doing it from like a mounted Windows volume within WSL2, which I shouldn't have been doing. But then even when I went to WSL2, it looks like it built in 30 minutes, but then I couldn't find the executable anywhere. Yeah, when I started off my career,|||这些适配器将在 C++ 23 中推出。我刚刚花了过去的时间——它已经运行大概四个小时了。我花了 22 个小时（包括睡觉时间），试图弄出一个能正常工作的 GCC 13.1 版本。天哪，天哪。我关于这个话题的最后一条推文是：我简直不敢相信，安装一个 Linux 操作系统竟然比获取一个前沿的 GCC 版本还要容易。我尝试编译了很长时间，让它运行了一整夜，结果没成功，但我当时是在 WSL2 中通过挂载的 Windows 卷来操作的，我不该这么做。但后来即使我切换到 WSL2，它看起来在 30 分钟内就构建完成了，但我到处都找不到可执行文件。是的，在我刚开始职业生涯的时候，
one of the first notable accomplishments that I have to my name is that I built the Linux kernel with Clang back in the day before that was a thing. And the reason that I undertook that project was that I had tried to build GCC on my own, and it went so poorly that I decided, you know what? It'll be easier to get the Linux kernel to build with Clang than it will be to build GCC. And I was right. I believe I was correct. I don't mean to cast shade. I think the GCC folks, they're doing a lot of amazing work.
one of the first notable accomplishments that I have to my name is that I built the Linux kernel with Clang back in the day before that was a thing. And the reason that I undertook that project was that I had tried to build GCC on my own, and it went so poorly that I decided, you know what? It'll be easier to get the Linux kernel to build with Clang than it will be to build GCC. And I was right. I believe I was correct. I don't mean to cast shade. I think the GCC folks, they're doing a lot of amazing work.|||我名下的第一个显著成就之一，就是在当年这件事还不存在的时候，用 Clang 构建了 Linux 内核。我之所以承担这个项目，是因为我曾试图自己构建 GCC，结果进展极其不顺利，以至于我决定：你知道吗？让 Linux 内核用 Clang 构建，比构建 GCC 要容易得多。我是对的。我相信我是对的。我不是想贬低谁。我觉得 GCC 的团队成员们，他们做了很多了不起的工作。
They're one of the leaders in C++ compiler implementation stuff. So they're doing great work, but I don't think it's unfair to say that I didn't actually end up building. I mean, I successfully built something, but at the end of the day, because I had initially tweeted out yesterday, what's like, how long is this usually supposed to take? And I have like a beefy thread ripper that NVIDIA has given me. So like, it's not like I'm doing this on a laptop from four years ago. And Matt Gobble, he just, he replied being like,
They're one of the leaders in C++ compiler implementation stuff. So they're doing great work, but I don't think it's unfair to say that I didn't actually end up building. I mean, I successfully built something, but at the end of the day, because I had initially tweeted out yesterday, what's like, how long is this usually supposed to take? And I have like a beefy thread ripper that NVIDIA has given me. So like, it's not like I'm doing this on a laptop from four years ago. And Matt Gobble, he just, he replied being like,|||他们是 C++ 编译器实现领域的领头羊之一。所以他们做得很棒，但我觉得说我最后其实并没有成功构建，这并不算不公。我的意思是，我确实成功构建了点东西，但归根结底，因为我昨天最初发推文问过：这通常应该花多长时间？而且我有一台 NVIDIA 送给我的强劲的线程撕裂者（Threadripper）。所以，这可不是我用四年前的笔记本电脑在做这种事。然后 Matt Gobble，他直接回复说：
you can just borrow the already compiled instance that's living on like an AWS box. Here's a link. And that took, I can't remember how long that took to download. It was an hour or two with a curl command command and i don't actually know the exact amount i just know it wasn't wasn't super fast but once i had that and figured out a bunch of other things eventually got it working but it's this is not to complain this is why did you need to build gcc
you can just borrow the already compiled instance that's living on like an AWS box. Here's a link. And that took, I can't remember how long that took to download. It was an hour or two with a curl command command and i don't actually know the exact amount i just know it wasn't wasn't super fast but once i had that and figured out a bunch of other things eventually got it working but it's this is not to complain this is why did you need to build gcc|||你可以直接借用一个已经编译好的实例，它就跑在类似 AWS 的机器上。给你个链接。这花了我——我不记得下载花了多长时间。用 curl 命令大概花了一两个小时，我其实不知道具体时间，只知道它不是超级快。但一旦我有了那个并搞定了一堆其他事情，最后它终于能工作了。但这并不是在抱怨，这是——你为什么又需要构建 GCC 呢？
again i need gcc so gcc trunk on godbolt has where trunk on Godbolt has been where I've been playing around with all of the C++23 range adapters. Like Chunkby. That's the biggest one. Adjacent Transform. It's just super exciting. And I have like work projects, two or three different personal projects that are either, you know, they're making heavy use of ranges, but then also I have to pull in the range V3 library, which I still think I actually am going to need for many of these projects because I use the fold left and right flavored algorithms that come in C++23. And unfortunately, GCC 13.1 doesn't ship with those. But the key thing that I need is that
again i need gcc so gcc trunk on godbolt has where trunk on Godbolt has been where I've been playing around with all of the C++23 range adapters. Like Chunkby. That's the biggest one. Adjacent Transform. It's just super exciting. And I have like work projects, two or three different personal projects that are either, you know, they're making heavy use of ranges, but then also I have to pull in the range V3 library, which I still think I actually am going to need for many of these projects because I use the fold left and right flavored algorithms that come in C++23. And unfortunately, GCC 13.1 doesn't ship with those. But the key thing that I need is that|||我需要 GCC，所以 Godbolt 上的 GCC trunk 一直是我用来试玩所有 C++23 范围适配器的地方。比如 Chunk-by。那是最大的一个。还有 Adjacent Transform。这简直太令人兴奋了。我有工作项目，还有两三个不同的个人项目，它们要么——你知道的，大量使用了 ranges，但同时我还得引入 range V3 库，我觉得在许多这样的项目中我实际上仍然需要它，因为我使用了 C++23 中自带的 fold left 和 fold right 风格的算法。不幸的是，GCC 13.1 并未自带这些算法。但我真正需要的关键点是，
in order to be able to pipe range adapters together, they need to be from the same source. So you can't mix piping range V3 range adapters and standard range adapters. And there is a proposal that... You might be able to soon because we added in 23 this ability to write range adapters that can compose with the standard range adapters. Yeah, there's a proposal.
in order to be able to pipe range adapters together, they need to be from the same source. So you can not mix piping range V3 range adapters and standard range adapters. And there is a proposal that... You might be able to soon because we added in 23 this ability to write range adapters that can compose with the standard range adapters. Yeah, there's a proposal.|||为了能够将范围适配器通过管道连接（pipe）在一起，它们必须来自同一个源。所以你不能把 range V3 的范围适配器和标准范围适配器混在一起进行管道操作。而且有一个提案……你可能很快就能这么做了，因为我们在 23 标准中添加了这样一种能力：编写能够与标准范围适配器组合的范围适配器。是的，有一个提案。
I'm not sure it actually made it in. I thought it did. I thought it did. I could be wrong. I'm only the C++ library evolution chair. I don't actually know things. But I thought that it went through. Maybe I'm only the C++ library evolution chair. I don't actually know things. But I thought that it went through. Maybe I'm incorrect.
I'm not sure it actually made it in. I thought it did. I thought it did. I could be wrong. I'm only the C++ library evolution chair. I don't actually know things. But I thought that it went through. Maybe I'm only the C++ library evolution chair. I don't actually know things. But I thought that it went through. Maybe I'm incorrect.|||我不确定它是否真的被采纳了。我以为是的。我以为是的。我也许记错了。我只是 C++ 库演进主席。我其实什么都不知道。但我以为它通过了。也许我只是 C++ 库演进主席。我其实什么都不知道。但我以为它通过了。也许我记错了。
Honestly, you probably have a better sense of what's going on in the ranges world than me. We will find a link, and I'm pretty sure it went through. I am pretty sure that's the case because I remember it being listed as a top two or three high-priority items in rangeland. But the point is we don't currently have that and so i've been i've been stuck with hand rolling certain versions of these things or basically just like in in the code the projects that i'm working on like where the place i need an adjacent transform i literally have comments that say like just wait till gcc 13's out which it is now and very exciting i have my adjacent transform in at least one of my projects working so the point is clap applause for all the all the wonderful people the gcc uh and thank you to
Honestly, you probably have a better sense of what's going on in the ranges world than me. We will find a link, and I'm pretty sure it went through. I am pretty sure that's the case because I remember it being listed as a top two or three high-priority items in rangeland. But the point is we don't currently have that and so i've been i've been stuck with hand rolling certain versions of these things or basically just like in in the code the projects that i'm working on like where the place i need an adjacent transform i literally have comments that say like just wait till gcc 13's out which it is now and very exciting i have my adjacent transform in at least one of my projects working so the point is clap applause for all the all the wonderful people the gcc uh and thank you to|||说实话，你对 ranges 领域发生的事情可能比我更清楚。我们会找个链接的，我确信它通过了。我非常确信是这样的，因为我记得它被列为 ranges 领域优先级前两三项的高优先级事项。但重点是，我们目前还没有这个功能，所以我一直——我不得不自己手动实现某些版本的这些东西，或者基本上就像在我正在编写的代码项目中，在需要 adjacent transform 的地方，我字面上有注释写着：“等 GCC 13 出来再说吧”——现在它确实出来了，非常令人兴奋，我的 adjacent transform 已经在至少一个项目中跑通了。所以重点是，为 GCC 的所有那些了不起的人们鼓掌，呃，谢谢
matt gobbalt for letting me borrow it is already compiled and i And I also, yeah, I'll link the tweets if you also want to download Matt Gobbold's version of GCC 13.1 instead of building yourself because I found that a much easier solution. Anyways, the point is this is an announcement about GCC 13.1. I think in a few episodes in the last four months, I've been talking about how GCC 13 is on the horizon
matt gobbalt for letting me borrow it is already compiled and i And I also, yeah, I'll link the tweets if you also want to download Matt Gobbold's version of GCC 13.1 instead of building yourself because I found that a much easier solution. Anyways, the point is this is an announcement about GCC 13.1. I think in a few episodes in the last four months, I've been talking about how GCC 13 is on the horizon|||Matt Gobbalt 让我借用他已经编译好的版本，而且我——我还会，是的，如果你们也想下载 Matt Gobbold 版本的 GCC 13.1 而不是自己构建，我会把推文链接放出来，因为我觉得这是一个容易得多的解决方案。不管怎样，重点是这是一个关于 GCC 13.1 的公告。我想在过去四个月的几期节目里，我一直在谈论 GCC 13 即将推出，
and it's exciting that it's out. All right, that's out of the way. Let's chat about conferences. What are the conferences that you're going to in the next two or three months? I leave here at the end of May, and I'm going to Core C++. In Israel? Yes. to core c++ in israel yes i'm flying i'm flying new york to toronto toronto to london staying there for a day then london to tel aviv and then i'm at core c++ and what talk are you giving at core c++ i think it's a talk called c++ horizons about my three favorite features or my the three features that
and it's exciting that it's out. All right, that's out of the way. Let's chat about conferences. What are the conferences that you're going to in the next two or three months? I leave here at the end of May, and I'm going to Core C++. In Israel? Yes. to core c++ in israel yes i'm flying i'm flying new york to toronto toronto to london staying there for a day then london to tel aviv and then i'm at core c++ and what talk are you giving at core c++ i think it's a talk called c++ horizons about my three favorite features or my the three features that|||现在它发布了，真的很令人兴奋。好了，闲话少说。我们来聊聊会议吧。在接下来的两三个月里，你要去参加哪些会议？我将在五月底离开这里，去参加 Core C++。在以色列？是的。去以色列的 Core C++，是的。我坐飞机，我从纽约飞多伦多，多伦多飞伦敦，在那里呆一天，然后从伦敦飞特拉维夫，接着我就在 Core C++ 大会了。你在 Core C++ 上要讲什么演讲？我想是一个叫作《C++ 地平线》（C++ Horizons）的演讲，讲的是我最喜欢的三个特性，或者说我最期待的
i'm most excited about that are on uh on the roadmap for c++ let me guess all right although i think i actually know this list because you mentioned them on a panel at that od3 con or whatever that was oh three was that what is it called in in texas when you were 3d con i don't know oh yeah it was pattern matching pattern matching uh executors and reflection correct yeah that's correct yeah all right um and then i'm going to uh this meetup in sofia uh bulgaria is that where the committee meeting is yeah it's right before the next C++ committee meeting. And I'm going to give that same talk there. I'm also going to give, I may be running a panel at Core C++. And I think I'm giving a short talk on the first day of the conference,
i'm most excited about that are on uh on the roadmap for c++ let me guess all right although i think i actually know this list because you mentioned them on a panel at that od3 con or whatever that was oh three was that what is it called in in texas when you were 3d con i don't know oh yeah it was pattern matching pattern matching uh executors and reflection correct yeah that's correct yeah all right um and then i'm going to uh this meetup in sofia uh bulgaria is that where the committee meeting is yeah it's right before the next C++ committee meeting. And I'm going to give that same talk there. I'm also going to give, I may be running a panel at Core C++. And I think I'm giving a short talk on the first day of the conference,|||C++ 路线图上的三个特性——让我猜猜。好吧，虽然我觉得我其实知道这个清单，因为你在那场 od3 con 还是什么的座谈会上提到过它们。哦，三，那是叫什么？你在德克萨斯州参加的那个叫 3D con 的会议吗？我不知道。哦，对了，是模式匹配（pattern matching）、模式匹配、呃，执行器（executors）和反射（reflection），对吧？是的，完全正确。是的，好的，嗯，然后我要去——呃，保加利亚索菲亚的这个聚会，委员会会议是在那里开吗？是的，它就在下一次 C++ 委员会会议之前。我也会在那里做同样的演讲。我可能还会在 Core C++ 上主持一个座谈会。我想我会在会议的第一天做一个简短的演讲，
at the opening session, about AI about AI assisted software engineering tools. That's two talks or that's like a different thing? I think it's like just like they asked they want to do like some short introductory like 20 minute talks at the at sort of the launch
at the opening session, about AI about AI assisted software engineering tools. That's two talks or that's like a different thing? I think it's like just like they asked they want to do like some short introductory like 20 minute talks at the at sort of the launch|||在开幕式上，关于 AI——关于 AI 辅助的软件工程工具。那是两场演讲还是说这是个不同的东西？我觉得就像是他们要求的那样，他们希望在会议开幕时做一些简短的、大约 20 分钟的介绍性演讲。
of the conference. Interesting. So that's two people at NVIDIA at two different conferences giving talks on LL c++ related stuff i don't know about the other person andre alexandrescu is oh yeah yeah i mean andre and i've been chatting about that he's giving a talk at cpp no i don't i can't remember it's code europe or something like that anyways okay and then uh and then i'm going to the c++ committee meeting in varna um and then i'm going from there to vienna and then you and i are renting a car and and i i i i will tell you uh you and i have a have a dear friend um my dear friend i don't actually know
of the conference. Interesting. So that's two people at NVIDIA at two different conferences giving talks on LL c++ related stuff i don't know about the other person andre alexandrescu is oh yeah yeah i mean andre and i've been chatting about that he's giving a talk at cpp no i don't i can't remember it's code europe or something like that anyways okay and then uh and then i'm going to the c++ committee meeting in varna um and then i'm going from there to vienna and then you and i are renting a car and and i i i i will tell you uh you and i have a have a dear friend my dear friend i don't actually know|||很有意思。所以这是 NVIDIA 的两个人，在两场不同的会议上做关于 LL C++ 相关内容的演讲——我不清楚另一个人，安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库（Andre Alexandrescu）是……哦，对，对，我和安德烈聊过这个，他在 CPP 上做演讲——不，我不记得了，是 Code Europe 还是别的什么。不管怎样，好吧，然后，嗯，然后我要去瓦尔纳参加 C++ 委员会会议，嗯，然后我从那里去维也纳，接着你和我租一辆车，然后——我——我要告诉你，嗯，你和我有一个——有一个好朋友，我的好朋友，我其实不知道
how well you know him but but my dear friend um lives in London, who happens to be Slovenian. And I saw him when I was in London last week. I was like, are you keeping me in the dark who this was? Who this is? I was trying to respect people's privacy. But okay, you've said it now. I mean, we just mentioned like three episodes ago. I can't remember.
how well you know him but but my dear friend um lives in London, who happens to be Slovenian. And I saw him when I was in London last week. I was like, are you keeping me in the dark who this was? Who this is? I was trying to respect people's privacy. But okay, you've said it now. I mean, we just mentioned like three episodes ago. I can't remember.|||你对他的了解有多深，但我的好朋友，嗯，住在伦敦，碰巧是个斯洛文尼亚人。我上周在伦敦时见过他。我当时想：你一直瞒着我这人是谁吗？这人是谁？我当时在试图尊重别人的隐私。但好吧，你现在说出来了。我的意思是，我们就在大概三期节目之前刚提到过。我记不清了。
We had some guest on. Was it Tristan? Tristan mentioned that I think Gasper was Slovenian and that it wasn't Tristan I told him about the road trip and he gave me some advice
We had some guest on. Was it Tristan? Tristan mentioned that I think Gasper was Slovenian and that it wasn't Tristan I told him about the road trip and he gave me some advice|||我们请过某个嘉宾。是 Tristan 吗？Tristan 提到过，我觉得 Gasper 是斯洛文尼亚人，不是 Tristan。我把自驾游的事告诉了他，他给我提了一些建议，
for the road trip which you and I will have to discuss in a future road trip planning meeting we're going to record podcasts on live while we're driving in the car. Yes. Because I have professional grade omnidirectional mic that we're just... Now, who's going to be doing the driving? You said you're not good at driving, right?
for the road trip which you and I will have to discuss in a future road trip planning meeting we're going to record podcasts on live while we're driving in the car. Yes. Because I have professional grade omnidirectional mic that we're just... Now, who's going to be doing the driving? You said you're not good at driving, right?|||关于这次自驾游的建议，你和我必须在以后的自驾游规划会议上讨论。我们打算在车里开车时现场录制播客。是的。因为我有一个专业级的全向麦克风，我们只要……那么，谁来开车？你说过你不太会开车，对吧？
Or you don't like driving? Well, that's what the girlfriend tells me. And the thing is that the girlfriend basically doesn't let me drive anymore. And so, yeah. But you don't drive at all. When's the last time you drove a car? I just drove this weekend. I went to Niagara-on-the-Lake and Niagara Falls with my mother.
Or you don't like driving? Well, that's what the girlfriend tells me. And the thing is that the girlfriend basically doesn't let me drive anymore. And so, yeah. But you don't drive at all. When's the last time you drove a car? I just drove this weekend. I went to Niagara-on-the-Lake and Niagara Falls with my mother.|||或者说你讨厌开车？嗯，我女朋友是这么对我的。问题是，我女朋友基本上不让我开车了。所以，是的。但你根本不开车啊。你上次开车是什么时候？我这个周末刚开过。我和我母亲去了滨湖尼亚加（Niagara-on-the-Lake）和尼亚加拉大瀑布。
I'm an ace driver. The story, here's a little anecdote. My mother taught me how to drive. My older sister won't like it. I'll tell a little bit of a longer version. Your older sister isn't listening to this. That's true. She'll never hear this. Someone sent it to her
I'm an ace driver. The story, here's a little anecdote. My mother taught me how to drive. My older sister won't like it. I'll tell a little bit of a longer version. Your older sister isn't listening to this. That's true. She'll never hear this. Someone sent it to her|||我是个王牌车手。这个故事，这里有个小插曲。我母亲教我开车的。我姐姐不会喜欢这个的。我来讲一个稍微长一点的版本。你姐姐又不会听这个。也对。她永远不会听到这个。有人把它发给她
and they'd have to know her info. My older sister is a year older than me. She learned to drive and we drove in this parking lot that was 10 minutes away from our house. That was the parking lot to what do you call it? NHL. Not NHL rink, but a WHL rink.
and they'd have to know her info. My older sister is a year older than me. She learned to drive and we drove in this parking lot that was 10 minutes away from our house. That was the parking lot to what do you call it? NHL. Not NHL rink, but a WHL rink.|||而且他们得知道她的信息。我姐姐比我大一岁。她学开车时，我们在离家 10 分钟的一个停车场练习。那是——怎么说呢——NHL 的停车场。不是 NHL 的冰场，而是 WHL 的冰场。
So it's quite big and there's no cars around unless there's like a hockey game going on. And so that's where my sister learned to drive. And I think it was like a month before she was allowed to leave the parking lot and drive home, which is, it's not like a, it's only a 10 minute drive home, but like that's how much time she, it took for her to drive home. When I went a year later, when I turned 16 and passed the L, uh, we went the first time we, my mom drove to the parking lot and then we drove around, did some stuff. And then she's like, okay, you can drive home.
So it's quite big and there's no cars around unless there's like a hockey game going on. And so that's where my sister learned to drive. And I think it was like a month before she was allowed to leave the parking lot and drive home, which is, it's not like a, it's only a 10 minute drive home, but like that's how much time she, it took for her to drive home. When I went a year later, when I turned 16 and passed the L, uh, we went the first time we, my mom drove to the parking lot and then we drove around, did some stuff. And then she's like, okay, you can drive home.|||所以它非常大，周围没有车，除非正好有冰球比赛。我姐姐就是在那里学会开车的。我想她花了一个月左右的时间，才被允许离开停车场开车回家。这其实不算什么——开车回家只要 10 分钟，但她花了那么多时间才敢开车回家。一年后我去学车时，当我 16 岁并通过了 L 牌考试，呃，第一次去的时候，我妈开车把车开到停车场，然后我们到处开着兜风，做了一些练习。接着她说：“好吧，你可以开车回家了。”
And, uh, and then when we went to learn how to parallel park, we literally spent like 20 minutes working on it. And then she's like, okay, like you're good to go. And the point being is I'm a natural driver, according to my mother, who had a class four license, which probably means nothing to 99% of the listeners. But in BC, that's like it's a step above a class five, which is what the regular folks have. And it means you can like. Why did she have a class four license? She used to drive uh like
And, uh, and then when we went to learn how to parallel park, we literally spent like 20 minutes working on it. And then she's like, okay, like you're good to go. And the point being is I'm a natural driver, according to my mother, who had a class four license, which probably means nothing to 99% of the listeners. But in BC, that's like it's a step above a class five, which is what the regular folks have. And it means you can like. Why did she have a class four license? She used to drive uh like|||然后，嗯，当我们去学侧方停车（parallel park）时，我们字面上只花了大约 20 分钟练习。接着她说：“好吧，你没问题了。”重点是，据我母亲说，我是一个天生的车手。我母亲拥有四级驾照（class four license），这对 99% 的听众来说可能毫无意义。但在 BC 省，这比普通人拥有的五级驾照（class five）要高一个级别。这意味着你可以——她为什么会有四级驾照？她过去常常开——呃，
limos and stuff like that i was hoping you were going to tell me she was a truck driver i don't think i think you need higher than a class four to drive a truck but uh for those limo driver not a limo um specifically but basically in order to drive people i guess that's sort of out the window now with uber but back in the day before peer-to-peer driving services if you wanted to drive a taxi cab or like a limo and like professionally drive people from point a to point b and get paid for it you had to have a class four and she used to for canadians uh you may know about this they used to have like world expos and uh the 1986 expo was held in vancouver uh b. And for that, she drove famous people around. And I don't know off the top of my head, but she drove some pretty famous people,
limos and stuff like that i was hoping you were going to tell me she was a truck driver i don't think i think you need higher than a class four to drive a truck but uh for those limo driver not a limo um specifically but basically in order to drive people i guess that's sort of out the window now with uber but back in the day before peer-to-peer driving services if you wanted to drive a taxi cab or like a limo and like professionally drive people from point a to point b and get paid for it you had to have a class four and she used to for canadians uh you may know about this they used to have like world expos and uh the 1986 expo was held in vancouver b. And for that, she drove famous people around. And I don't know off the top of my head, but she drove some pretty famous people,|||比如加长轿车（limo）之类的好车。我本来希望你告诉我她是个卡车司机。我觉得开卡车需要的驾照级别应该比四级高，但呃，对于那些——豪华轿车司机，不完全是豪华轿车，嗯，具体来说，基本上为了载客——我想现在有了 Uber，这种职业已经有点过时了，但在过去，在点对点代驾服务出现之前，如果你想开出租车或豪华轿车，并且专业地把人们从 A 点载到 B 点并因此获得报酬，你就必须拥有四级驾照。她过去常常——对于加拿大人来说，呃，你们可能知道这个，他们过去经常举办世界博览会，1986 年的世博会在温哥华举行。为此，她曾开车带着名人们到处转。我记不清具体名字了，但她确实载过一些相当有名的人物，
which is a pretty cool job back when you're young. I think she was like, I actually know exactly how old. In 1986, she was 22. So, yeah. Great story. Point being, she was 22. So yeah. Great story. Point being, I can do all the driving. Great. Well, we're definitely going to die on this road trip.
which is a pretty cool job back when you're young. I think she was like, I actually know exactly how old. In 1986, she was 22. So, yeah. Great story. Point being, she was 22. So yeah. Great story. Point being, I can do all the driving. Great. Well, we're definitely going to die on this road trip.|||对于年轻时的她来说，这是一份相当酷的工作。我想她当时——我其实确切知道她多大。1986 年时她 22 岁。所以，是的。好故事。重点是，她当时 22 岁。所以，是的。好故事。重点是，我可以包揽所有的驾驶。太棒了。好吧，我们在这次自驾游中绝对会死掉的。
Why? You'll just have to hold the mic. You'll be in charge of the mic because we've only got one mic. So we'll go back and forth. I think the listeners right now are hearing this and they're getting real excited for these live from slovenia on the road headed to bread lake or is it bled lake i keep bled lake i keep getting feedback at conferences about what on the podcast like at at uh accu somebody came up to me and he's like hey i listened to the podcast and you guys you guys
Why? You'll just have to hold the mic. You'll be in charge of the mic because we've only got one mic. So we'll go back and forth. I think the listeners right now are hearing this and they're getting real excited for these live from slovenia on the road headed to bread lake or is it bled lake i keep bled lake i keep getting feedback at conferences about what on the podcast like at at uh accu somebody came up to me and he's like hey i listened to the podcast and you guys you guys|||为什么？你只需要拿着麦克风就行。你将负责拿麦克风，因为我们只有一个麦克风。所以我们会轮流拿。我觉得现在的听众听到这里，一定会对这些从斯洛文尼亚发出的现场播客感到非常兴奋——在开往布雷德湖（Bread lake）的路上，还是布莱德湖（bled lake）？我老是——是布莱德湖。我在会议上不断收到关于播客内容的反馈，比如在——呃，在 ACCU 上，有人走到我面前说：嘿，我听了这个播客，你们俩——你们俩
just got to stop the stop the live coding it's too hard to follow one for guys like that i'm like but but the way he put it it was so great it was so great he was like i'm here doing my dishes and you got like just like if you want it to be a youtube channel it should be a youtube channel i'm like yeah probably should have just been like yeah like video but i just thought i was just like i'm here doing my dishes like i can't i can't follow what what you're doing with the code well admittedly how many times we've made a decision at some point to stop sharing our screen and then you went ahead and did that whole views filter thing had me read it out and like i started that off being like we made an agreement bryce we weren't
just got to stop the stop the live coding it's too hard to follow one for guys like that i'm like but but the way he put it it was so great it was so great he was like i'm here doing my dishes and you got like just like if you want it to be a youtube channel it should be a youtube channel i'm like yeah probably should have just been like yeah like video but i just thought i was just like i'm here doing my dishes like i can't i can't follow what what you're doing with the code well admittedly how many times we've made a decision at some point to stop sharing our screen and then you went ahead and did that whole views filter thing had me read it out and like i started that off being like we made an agreement bryce we weren't|||必须停止——停止现场写代码，这太难跟上了！像这种人，我就觉得——但他表达的方式太棒了，太棒了！他当时说：“我正在这儿洗碗呢，而你们俩——这感觉就像如果你们想做成一个 YouTube 频道，那就应该去当 YouTube 频道。”我就想：对啊，也许我们本来就该做成视频那样的。但我当时觉得——我当时在想：“我正洗着碗呢，我根本——根本跟不上你们在代码里搞的那些东西。”好吧，诚然，我们曾在某个时刻多次做出决定停止共享屏幕，然后你还是自顾自地搞了那个 views 过滤器的东西，还让我把它读出来。我一开始就说：“我们说好了的，Bryce，我们不——”
going to do this and then you like, we're a coding podcast. We got to do it. So we promise henceforth, going forward. Thank you. I'm not – I can't make that promise. I'm making the promise. I'm just going to – The promise that we can make is we'll focus more on guests.
going to do this and then you like, we're a coding podcast. We got to do it. So we promise henceforth, going forward. Thank you. I'm not – I can't make that promise. I'm making the promise. I'm just going to – The promise that we can make is we'll focus more on guests.|||打算这么做的，然后你就觉得：我们是个编程播客啊，我们必须得这么干。所以我们在此承诺，今后，从今往后。谢谢。我不会——我没法做出那个承诺。这个承诺我来做。我只会——我们能做出的承诺是，我们会更多地关注嘉宾。
We'll focus more – like when we have guests on, we're not doing live coding. I think that's always fun and informational for people. So we should focus more on guests. Let's bring up the uh we already focus we do have a pretty good quite heavily if i look at i guess if you're if you're if you're the the people that listen to this podcast in slovenia and like you want to be on the podcast let us know so we can include you in our road trip plans. Out of our last 15 podcasts, what is that, three, five, ten of them. So we're at a two-thirds guest episode.
We'll focus more – like when we have guests on, we're not doing live coding. I think that's always fun and informational for people. So we should focus more on guests. Let's bring up the – we already focus we do have a pretty good quite heavily if i look at i guess if you're if you're if you're the the people that listen to this podcast in slovenia and like you want to be on the podcast let us know so we can include you in our road trip plans. Out of our last 15 podcasts, what is that, three, five, ten of them. So we're at a two-thirds guest episode.|||我们会更多地关注——比如当有嘉宾做客时，我们就不搞现场写代码了。我觉得这总是很有趣，也能为人们提供很多信息。所以我们应该更多地关注嘉宾。让我们谈谈——我们其实已经关注了，我们的确有很多——如果我看看的话，我想如果你是——如果你是那些在斯洛文尼亚收听这个播客、并且想上播客的人，请让我们知道，这样我们就可以把你们纳入我们的自驾游计划中。在我们最近的 15 期播客中，有几期是这样的：3期、5期、10期。所以我们的嘉宾访谈节目占了三分之二。
So that's pretty good. And admittedly, we probably would have had a guest today, but this was kind of last minute. And the next month for, I think, me and probably you as well is going to be a bit crazy. Anyways, road. No, no, no. Next month, I'm at home. The next month is like the quiet month.
So that's pretty good. And admittedly, we probably would have had a guest today, but this was kind of last minute. And the next month for, I think, me and probably you as well is going to be a bit crazy. Anyways, road. No, no, no. Next month, I'm at home. The next month is like the quiet month.|||这相当不错。诚然，我们今天本来可能会有一位嘉宾的，但这有点太临时了。而且接下来一个月，对我和你来说大概都会有点疯狂。不管怎样，路。不，不，不。下个月，我在家。下个月简直是个平静的月份。
All right. Well. Until the summer. We will take advantage of that. So Slovenia, Vienna, going to Venice. You got conferences after that as well, or are you just heading home after that? Then I fly home for, it was going to be three days, but now it's four days. That was the thing I was on the phone with the airline about earlier.
All right. Well. Until the summer. We will take advantage of that. So Slovenia, Vienna, going to Venice. You got conferences after that as well, or are you just heading home after that? Then I fly home for, it was going to be three days, but now it's four days. That was the thing I was on the phone with the airline about earlier.|||好吧。好吧。直到夏天。我们会好好利用这一点的。所以是斯洛文尼亚、维也纳，然后去威尼斯。你之后还有会议吗，还是说之后就直接回家了？然后我飞回家待几天——本来打算待三天，现在变成四天了。这就是我刚才一直在跟航空公司通电话商量的事。
And then I fly to London for CPP on C for, I'm going to be there for like two or three days and then I fly back. And then we're going somewhere for vacation on July 4th weekend. I just haven't figured out where or how are those logistical details. Are you giving the same Horizons talk at C++ on C? No, I'm giving a a talk on uh ai assisted software engineering what happened to i thought i saw somewhere you were going to give a talk called empire is that true or false i don't think i've nope that's unfortunate because I thought that talk was going to be about a reference to Star Wars, The Empire Strikes Back. No. Well, there's a talk idea for you.
And then I fly to London for CPP on C for, I'm going to be there for like two or three days and then I fly back. And then we're going somewhere for vacation on July 4th weekend. I just haven't figured out where or how are those logistical details. Are you giving the same Horizons talk at C++ on C? No, I'm giving a a talk on uh ai assisted software engineering what happened to i thought i saw somewhere you were going to give a talk called empire is that true or false i don't think i've nope that's unfortunate because I thought that talk was going to be about a reference to Star Wars, The Empire Strikes Back. No. Well, there's a talk idea for you.|||然后我飞往伦敦参加 CPP on C 大会，我会在那里呆两三天，然后飞回来。接着在 7 月 4 日国庆周末，我们会去某个地方度假。我只是还没想好去哪儿，以及那些后勤细节怎么安排。你在 C++ on C 上也要做那个《地平线》的同款演讲吗？不，我要做一个关于——呃，AI 辅助软件工程的演讲。怎么回事？我以为我在某个地方看到你要做一个叫《帝国》（Empire）的演讲，这是真的还是假的？我觉得我没有——没有。真遗憾，因为我还以为那个演讲会是关于《星球大战：帝国反击战》（Star Wars, The Empire Strikes Back）的梗呢。不是。好吧，这倒是个给你的演讲创意。
For some reason, I thought I saw that talk, your name next to that title somewhere, but I guess I just made that up. Yeah. And then, I mean, I'm not doing much over the summer. Not sure if I'm going to CPP Toronto or CPP North. Going to give a talk at CPP India Con in August. And then that's pretty much it. That's pretty much my...
For some reason, I thought I saw that talk, your name next to that title somewhere, but I guess I just made that up. Yeah. And then, I mean, I'm not doing much over the summer. Not sure if I'm going to CPP Toronto or CPP North. Going to give a talk at CPP India Con in August. And then that's pretty much it. That's pretty much my...|||出于某种原因，我以为我看到了那个演讲，你的名字和那个标题出现在某个地方，但我想我大概是凭空捏造出来的。是的。然后，我的意思是，我在夏天不会安排太多活动。不确定是否会去 CPP Toronto 或 CPP North。八月份要去 CPP India Con 做一个演讲。然后基本上就是这样了。这差不多就是我的……
I may have a quiet-ish summer. C++ on C. Schedule. Who are the keynotes? Oh, I'm keynoting. Sean Parent. Probably. Probably should have led with that. Lisa Lippincott.
I may have a quiet-ish summer. C++ on C. Schedule. Who are the keynotes? Oh, I'm keynoting. Sean Parent. Probably. Probably should have led with that. Lisa Lippincott.|||我的夏天可能会相对平静一些。C++ on C。日程安排。主旨演讲嘉宾（keynote）都有谁？哦，我是主旨演讲嘉宾。Sean Parent。可能吧。我可能应该先介绍这个。Lisa Lippincott。
And Bryce Lelback. We'll leave links to all of these in the show notes. So, yeah, all of those conferences you can find Bryce at. What's my schedule? I'm going to a first conference is in May and it's KXCon, which is a conference being put on
And Bryce Lelback. We'll leave links to all of these in the show notes. So, yeah, all of those conferences you can find Bryce at. What's my schedule? I'm going to a first conference is in May and it's KXCon, which is a conference being put on|||还有 Bryce Lelback。我们会在节目简介中留下所有这些会议的链接。所以，是的，在所有这些会议上你都能找到 Bryce。我的日程是怎样的？我要去参加的第一场会议在五月份，是 KXCon，这是一个由
by the company KX, which is the company that owns the Q programming language. Where is that? That's in Montauk, New York. So I fly into into la guardia and then i'm renting a car and it's like a three-hour drive to the tip of wait when are you doing this it's may 17th to 20th and you you didn't like you weren't gonna inform me of that i mean i'm not in
by the company KX, which is the company that owns the Q programming language. Where is that? That's in Montauk, New York. So I fly into into la guardia and then i'm renting a car and it's like a three-hour drive to the tip of wait when are you doing this it's may 17th to 20th and you you didn't like you weren't gonna inform me of that i mean i'm not in|||KX 公司举办的会议，这家公司拥有 Q 编程语言。那是在哪儿？在纽约蒙托克（Montauk）。所以我飞到拉瓜迪亚机场（LaGuardia），然后租一辆车，大概开三个小时的车程到达——等等，你什么时候去？是 5 月 17 日到 20 日。而你——你居然没打算告诉我这件事？我的意思是，我不在——
new york the city i'm in montau, which is like four hours away from New York. It's on Long Island. It's at the very end of Long Island, which is quite long, to be totally honest. Yeah. Really, it's in Montauk. Okay. Yep. Well, you're going to have to come hang out
new york the city i'm in montau, which is like four hours away from New York. It's on Long Island. It's at the very end of Long Island, which is quite long, to be totally honest. Yeah. Really, it's in Montauk. Okay. Yep. Well, you're going to have to come hang out|||纽约市，我在蒙托克，距离纽约大约四个小时车程。它在长岛上。它在长岛的最末端，说实话，长岛真的很长。是的。真的，在蒙托克。好的。是的。好吧，你得来跟我——
with me. Nope. I'm sorry. That wasn't a request. And it was heard and denied. What time are you getting into LaGuardia? I think I land at like 9.30 or 10. And then I'm renting a car and like immediately driving out. 9.30 or 10 a.m. or p.m.? A.m.
with me. Nope. I'm sorry. That wasn't a request. And it was heard and denied. What time are you getting into LaGuardia? I think I land at like 9.30 or 10. And then I'm renting a car and like immediately driving out. 9.30 or 10 a.m. or p.m.? A.m.|||一起玩。才不要。抱歉。那不是一个请求。你的请求已被收到并拒绝。你几点到拉瓜迪亚机场？我想我大概 9 点半或 10 点降落。然后我租辆车，马上就开车出发。上午 9 点半或 10 点，还是晚上？上午。
Oh. Well, you're going to have a fun drive.m or p.m a.m oh well you're gonna have a fun drive why oh there's just there's gonna be some traffic buddy yeah that's fine and then uh i leave on saturday at four why are you renting a car how else am i supposed to get to montauk i would have thought there was a train but there's absolutely no transit from what i could tell no train when i search travel to montau thought there was a train. There's absolutely no transit from what I could tell. No train. When I searched travel to Montauk. There's a...
Oh. Well, you'll have a fun drive.m or p.m a.m oh well you're gonna have a fun drive why oh there's just there's gonna be some traffic buddy yeah that's fine and then uh i leave on saturday at four why are you renting a car how else am i supposed to get to montauk i would have thought there was a train but there's absolutely no transit from what i could tell no train when i search travel to montau thought there was a train. There's absolutely no transit from what I could tell. No train. When I searched travel to Montauk. There's a...|||哦。好吧，你会有一次愉快的车程的。上午还是下午？上午。哦。好吧，你会有一次愉快的车程的。为什么？哦，路上会有不少车堵着的，老兄。是的，没关系。然后，嗯，我周六下午四点离开。你为什么要租车？不然我怎么去蒙托克？我本来以为有火车，但据我所知，完全没有任何公共交通。当我搜索去蒙托克的出行方式时，根本没有火车。我以为有火车。据我所知，完全没有任何公共交通。没有火车。当我搜索去蒙托克的出行方式时。有一个……
Yeah, there's a train. It's called the Montauk Branch. It goes right to Montauk. It's a Long Island Railroad line. I think you pick it up at Jamaica Station. Like, I just Google maps. Man, that's pretty sad. Because when I searched this, this wasn't possible.
Yeah, there's a train. It's called the Montauk Branch. It goes right to Montauk. It's a Long Island Railroad line. I think you pick it up at Jamaica Station. Like, I just Google maps. Man, that's pretty sad. Because when I searched this, this wasn't possible.|||对，有火车。它叫 Montauk 支线。直达蒙托克。那是长岛铁路（Long Island Railroad）的一条线路。我想你在牙买加车站（Jamaica Station）上车。我就用 Google 地图查了下。天哪，那可真够惨的。因为我当时搜索时，这根本行不通。
Actually, maybe I didn't check Montauk. Maybe I checked the resort. Yeah, you should. I mean, I think it's going to take you as long to drive. I mean, I would have preferred. I don't want to rent a car. Yeah, see? The resort is Gurney's Montauk Resort.
Actually, maybe I didn't check Montauk. Maybe I checked the resort. Yeah, you should. I mean, I think it's going to take you as long to drive. I mean, I would have preferred. I don't want to rent a car. Yeah, see? The resort is Gurney's Montauk Resort.|||事实上，也许我查的不是蒙托克。也许我查的是度假村。对，你应该查查。我的意思是，我觉得你开车花的时间也差不多。我的意思是，我本来更倾向于——我不想租车。对吧，你看？那个度假村叫 Gurney's Montauk Resort。
If you plug that in, they give you no options. There's no options. I'm sure that they got a shuttle or something. I know. I think they have a shuttle to Montauk, but I did not check that. I just plugged in Gurney's, and it says that there's no – so note to future people, if you're going to Montauk, there is a train, which I did not – I wonder if I can cancel.
If you plug that in, they give you no options. There's no options. I'm sure that they got a shuttle or something. I know. I think they have a shuttle to Montauk, but I did not check that. I just plugged in Gurney's, and it says that there's no – so note to future people, if you're going to Montauk, there is a train, which I did not – I wonder if I can cancel.|||如果你把这个输入进去，他们不会给你提供任何选项。根本没有选项。我确信他们有班车什么的。我知道。我想他们有去蒙托克的班车，但我没查那个。我只是输入了 Gurney's，然后它显示没有——所以给未来的人提个醒，如果你要去蒙托克，是有火车的，而我当时没有——我在想我能不能取消预订？
I'll look into that. Your rental car? Yeah, you probably can. I mean, if you booked it properly. I mean, some of them you can't cancel. Anyways, these are... That's what I meant by if you booked it properly. We'll fix that later.
I'll look into that. Your rental car? Yeah, you probably can. I mean, if you booked it properly. I mean, some of them you can't cancel. Anyways, these are... That's what I meant by if you booked it properly. We'll fix that later.|||我会去查查的。你的租车？对，你大概可以取消。我是说，如果你预订的方式对的话。我的意思是，有些是不能取消的。不管怎样，这些是——这就是我说的“如果你预订的方式对的话”的意思。我们待会儿再解决这个问题。
Well, these are uninteresting details. I'm giving a talk called Algorithms in Q at that conference. Should be exciting. Next conference is... Maybe I'm going to come out and hang out with you. Maybe. Maybe. It looks like a nice resort. So if if you want to you're more than welcome to
Well, these are uninteresting details. I'm giving a talk called Algorithms in Q at that conference. Should be exciting. Next conference is... Maybe I'm going to come out and hang out with you. Maybe. Maybe. It looks like a nice resort. So if if you want to you're more than welcome to|||好吧，这些都是无聊的细节。我在那场会议上将做一个名为《Q 中的算法》（Algorithms in Q）的演讲。应该会很精彩。下一场会议是……也许我会过去跟你一起玩。也许吧。也许。看起来是个不错的度假村。所以如果你愿意的话，非常欢迎你
the next conference is lambda days june 5th june 6th in krakow poland given a talk called composition intuition that's also going to be fire the next conference after that is italian c++ on i think it's june 10th yeah i couldn't make that i couldn't make that one work i would like i would have had to like fly from bulgaria to rome and like for one day and then fly right back that was just not going to work yeah that's not it's not viable um or just a bit bit too crazy well and it's also it's like i can't you know how many times in my life am i going to go to bulgaria um and i'm going to rome for five days in september yeah so yeah better to better to i would i would have loved to have gone to that conference it sounds like it's a cool conference um but maybe
the next conference is lambda days june 5th june 6th in krakow poland given a talk called composition intuition that's also going to be fire the next conference after that is italian c++ on i think it's june 10th yeah i couldn't make that i couldn't make that one work i would like i would have had to like fly from bulgaria to rome and like for one day and then fly right back that was just not going to work yeah that's not it's not viable um or just a bit bit too crazy well and it's also it's like i can't you know how many times in my life am i going to go to bulgaria um and i'm going to rome for five days in september yeah so yeah better to better to i would i would have loved to have gone to that conference it sounds like it's a cool conference um but maybe|||下一场会议是 Lambda Days，6 月 5 日至 6 月 6 日在波兰克拉科夫举行，演讲题目是《组合直觉》（Composition Intuition），那场也一定会非常火爆。再下一场会议是意大利 C++ 大会，我想是在 6 月 10 日。是的，我没法去那场，我赶不上那场。我本来需要——比如从保加利亚飞到罗马，待上一天，然后马上飞回来，那是根本行不通的。是的，那不——那不可行，嗯，或者说有点太疯狂了。而且这也是——这就好像我不能——你知道我这辈子能去多少次保加利亚，嗯，而且我九月份要在罗马待五天。所以，是的，最好还是——我本非常想去那场会议的，听起来是个很酷的会议，嗯，但也许
next year yeah i've given a given a virtual talk during the pandemic at it but have never been in person and i've also never been to Italy, so that'll be exciting. Yeah, me neither. And that conference I'll be giving a talk called New Algorithms in C++23, which little preview for the listener. Very excited that GCC 13.1 is going to be out so that I can actually have, well, I mean,
next year yeah i've given a given a virtual talk during the pandemic at it but have never been in person and i've also never been to Italy, so that'll be exciting. Yeah, me neither. And that conference I'll be giving a talk called New Algorithms in C++23, which little preview for the listener. Very excited that GCC 13.1 is going to be out so that I can actually have, well, I mean,|||明年吧。是的，我在大流行期间曾在该会议上做过虚拟演讲，但从未去过现场，而且我也从未去过意大利，所以那一定会令人兴奋。是的，我也是。在那场会议上，我将做一个名为《C++23 中的新算法》（New Algorithms in C++23）的演讲，给听众一个小小的剧透。非常高兴 GCC 13.1 即将发布，这样我实际上可以——好吧，我的意思是，
I could have had GodBull links as well, but now I can actually say that you can go and download this and run it locally. But on top of that, I pinged Sean Baxter and asked him if he had implemented the pipeline operator that's been proposed for C++26, which sounds like, according to folks, Zach said that that was dead in the water and now Barry's working on some Rust traits like thing and we might not get the placeholder or the pipeline and placeholder. But in asking Sean, he said no because he thought that the sort of proposal was in flux. And I said, ah, Barry made a bunch of recommendations. Anyways, he is in the midst of finalizing changes to support that
I could have had GodBull links as well, but now I can actually say that you can go and download this and run it locally. But on top of that, I pinged Sean Baxter and asked him if he had implemented the pipeline operator that's been proposed for C++26, which sounds like, according to folks, Zach said that that was dead in the water and now Barry's working on some Rust traits like thing and we might not get the placeholder or the pipeline and placeholder. But in asking Sean, he said no because he thought that the sort of proposal was in flux. And I said, ah, Barry made a bunch of recommendations. Anyways, he is in the midst of finalizing changes to support that|||我本来也可以提供 Godbolt 链接的，但现在我终于可以实实在在地对大家说：你可以去下载这个并在本地运行了。不仅如此，我还联系了 Sean Baxter，问他是否实现了 C++26 提案中的管道操作符（pipeline operator）。听大家说，Zach 曾表示那个提案已经泡汤了，现在 Barry 正在搞一些类似 Rust trait 的东西，我们可能拿不到占位符（placeholder）或管道加占位符了。但在问 Sean 时，他说没有，因为他认为那个提案目前还在变动中。我说：啊，Barry 提出了一堆建议。不管怎样，他目前正在最终敲定支持该特性的修改，
in Circle. So my C++ talk might actually be a Circle talk because, I mean, it's basically going to be the same thing, just the Circle examples are going to look slightly nicer because everything I'll be able to pipe to instead of just things that have the pipe operator overloaded. Anyways, so if that ends up working, half my examples are going to have a Circle logo in the top left-hand corner instead of a C++ logo, which will be pretty fire. Well, but as Sean will tell you,
in Circle. So my C++ talk might actually be a Circle talk because, I mean, it's basically going to be the same thing, just the Circle examples are going to look slightly nicer because everything I'll be able to pipe to instead of just things that have the pipe operator overloaded. Anyways, so if that ends up working, half my examples are going to have a Circle logo in the top left-hand corner instead of a C++ logo, which will be pretty fire. Well, but as Sean will tell you,|||以便在 Circle 中提供支持。所以我的 C++ 演讲实际上可能会变成一场 Circle 演讲，因为，我的意思是，它基本上是一样的东西，只是 Circle 的示例看起来会稍微好看一点，因为我将能够把内容管道传输到任何东西，而不仅仅是那些重载了管道操作符的对象。不管怎样，如果最后成功了，我的一半示例在左上角都会有一个 Circle 的标志，而不是 C++ 的标志，那会相当酷炫。不过，正如 Sean 会告诉你的那样，
Circle is not its own language. In his worldview, Circle is just a better C++ compiler. Yes. I mean, I would not disagree with that. Circle is an evolved C++. But if it's going to start, I'll tell you, if C++ 26 doesn't end up getting a pipeline operator and I can just use Circle and everything else works and I get the pipeline operator, Circle now becomes like my default language, quote unquote, of choice just because of that one feature. And I was just watching a presentation that was talking about all
Circle is not its own language. In his worldview, Circle is just a better C++ compiler. Yes. I mean, I would not disagree with that. Circle is an evolved C++. But if it's going to start, I'll tell you, if C++ 26 doesn't end up getting a pipeline operator and I can just use Circle and everything else works and I get the pipeline operator, Circle now becomes like my default language, quote unquote, of choice just because of that one feature. And I was just watching a presentation that was talking about all|||Circle 不是一门独立的语言。在他的世界观里，Circle 只是一个更好的 C++ 编译器。是的。我的意思是，我对此并不反对。Circle 是一个进化的 C++。但如果它开始——我告诉你，如果 C++ 26 最终没有引入管道操作符，而我只要使用 Circle 就能让其他一切正常工作，并且还能获得管道操作符，那么仅仅因为这一个特性，Circle 就会成为我默认的、所谓的首选语言。我刚才还在看一个演讲，里面谈到了
the stuff that Circle supports, like language tuples and language variants. And like, I don't need that stuff. Same way, I don't really need the pipeline operator, but I would love to have that stuff. I would be a little bit concerned with language tuple and language variant because then your code is going to become, like, to some extent incompatible with C++, and it would increase the number of changes you'd have to go and do. But my point being is that I might be on the precipice. You know, I was on the precipice of falling in love with Rust. But then I think things got too busy at work and I stopped learning Rust. Although it's still on the list of things to do. But anyways, point is, Circle.
the stuff that Circle supports, like language tuples and language variants. And like, I don't need that stuff. Same way, I don't really need the pipeline operator, but I would love to have that stuff. I would be a little bit concerned with language tuple and language variant because then your code is going to become, like, to some extent incompatible with C++, and it would increase the number of changes you'd have to go and do. But my point being is that I might be on the precipice. You know, I was on the precipice of falling in love with Rust. But then I think things got too busy at work and I stopped learning Rust. Although it's still on the list of things to do. But anyways, point is, Circle.|||Circle 支持的所有东西，比如语言级元组（language tuples）和语言级变体（language variants）。而且，我不需要那些东西。同理，我其实也不是非要管道操作符不可，但我真的很想要那些功能。我对语言级元组和语言级变体有点担心，因为那样的话，你的代码在某种程度上会与 C++ 不兼容，这会增加你需要去做的修改量。但我的意思是，我可能正处于悬崖边缘。你知道的，我曾经差点就爱上了 Rust。但后来我觉得工作太忙了，就没继续学 Rust。尽管它仍然在我的待办事项列表上。但不管怎样，重点是 Circle。
Very excited to test this pipeline operator version out. Anyways, let's wrap this up. Then there's a couple week breaks. I'll be taking some vacation time. We're doing that road trip. And then I'll be going to visit my sister in Ireland. And then after that, going to C++ on C where I'm giving the same talk, but it'll be a 90-minute version instead of a 45-minute version. And then coming back to Canada. And in mid-July,
Very excited to test this pipeline operator version out. Anyways, let's wrap this up. Then there's a couple week breaks. I'll be taking some vacation time. We're doing that road trip. And then I'll be going to visit my sister in Ireland. And then after that, going to C++ on C where I'm giving the same talk, but it'll be a 90-minute version instead of a 45-minute version. And then coming back to Canada. And in mid-July,|||非常兴奋能测试这个带管道操作符的版本。不管怎样，我们总结一下吧。接下来有几个星期的假期。我会休一段假。我们要去进行那次自驾游。然后我会去爱尔兰探望我姐姐。之后去参加 C++ on C 大会，我会在那里做同样的演讲，但那将是一个 90 分钟的版本，而不是 45 分钟的版本。然后回到加拿大。在七月中旬，
going to be back at CPP North, giving a 90-minute version of that talk as well. And that is all I have planned. So there you have it, folks. Links in the description. If you are in, what were all the cities you were in? Sofia, Israel. We're both in London. Toronto. Or anywhere in like Austria, Slovenia, or like northeastern Italy.
going to be back at CPP North, giving a 90-minute version of that talk as well. And that is all I have planned. So there you have it, folks. Links in the description. If you are in, what were all the cities you were in? Sofia, Israel. We're both in London. Toronto. Or anywhere in like Austria, Slovenia, or like northeastern Italy.|||我会回到 CPP North，同样做那个演讲的 90 分钟版本。这就是我所有的计划了。各位，情况就是这样。简介中有链接。如果你在——你都去过哪些城市？索菲亚、以色列。我们俩都在伦敦。多伦多。或者在奥地利、斯洛文尼亚、或意大利东北部等任何地方。
Yep. Feel free to come and say hi. We'll have our mic on us at all times. Maybe not all times, but we'll be ready to do little mini interviews. And you could end up being on the pod. All right. Anything else we should say before we sign off? Imbal's not back.
Yep. Feel free to come and say hi. We'll have our mic on us at all times. Maybe not all times, but we'll be ready to do little mini interviews. And you could end up being on the pod. All right. Anything else we should say before we sign off? Imbal's not back.|||是的。随时欢迎来打招呼。我们的麦克风会一直随身携带。也许不一定是所有时间，但我们随时准备好做一些小型采访。你最后甚至可能会上我们的播客。好吧。在我们结束之前还有什么要说的吗？Imbal 还没回来。
Yeah, I should check on that. Hopefully she's not just waiting outside of the door. No, I've got no notification from her. Yeah? Well, we can splice it in later when she does maybe show up. All right. We'll call this the end then. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a
Yeah, I should check on that. Hopefully she's not just waiting outside of the door. No, I've got no notification from her. Yeah? Well, we can splice it in later when she does maybe show up. All right. We'll call this the end then. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a|||对，我得去看看。希望她不是正等在门外。没有，我没收到她的通知。是吗？好吧，等她也许出现时，我们再把那段剪辑进去吧。好的。那我们就此结束吧。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目简介，或者访问 ADSPthepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何事物的链接，以及一个
GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, questions, or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, questions, or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下评论、问题或想法。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。